well I'm George in the studio now by the
shadows secretary for international
trade Barry Gardner mostly thanks for
being with us after a difficult week for
the party we know that some of your
shadow cabinet colleagues were shall we
say slightly more reluctant to be
grilled on a Sunday morning political
show no braver than they were oh we
should start off by talking about
Copeland yes a seat that Labour had held
since the 1930s I mean that was a pretty
devastating verdict on what your part is
offering wasn't it
look it was it was it was a terrible
night for us
and we went down by what six silver
seven percentage points in the polls in
Copeland and and this is a seat which
although it's been reducing in in the
labor of majority for many many years
actually if you look over 15 years it's
got less and less each time but
nonetheless it was a seat we desperately
wanted to win
I think 62 seats that were more marginal
than Copeland's
well yes but I I mean I think there are
there were peculiarities that the
electorate is always I think rightly a
bit fed up when a member of parliament
decides that they're going to leave for
their own reasons rather because Jamie
reelect no no no absolutely not look
Jamie was a great MP and and one of the
things that of course he did provide
huge reassurance for the people of
Copeland arm was over the nuclear issue
and it was one of the issues that really
hit us in that in that by-election
because of course it was so important
Sellafield being the major employer
Moorside and being absolutely vital for
future jobs in that area and and of
course the the publicity that was put
out by the other party was was of course
an attack attack decades this features
that jeremy corbyn it may he was amazing
nuclear power yeah and you know we tried
to counter that we tried to say very
clearly look jeremy has always accepted
that nuclear is part of the the energy
mix going forward and you know he he has
as part of the Labour Party
it's the Labour Party positioned it's
what he in fact he produced an speech
after speech during that and
that campaign saying precisely that so
but nonetheless we lost it I mean that's
that's the bottom line and there's no
gilding that that particular problem and
I think we have to look though more
widely and I think we have to say look
what's happening in British politics is
really a fundamental shifting of the
ground this is not simply about Copeland
it's not simply about and it you see
still we won on them of course delighted
that we did and delighted that we
defeated you Kip and Paul Nuttall there
but actually in Stoke as well we lost
share of the vote and we have to take
that seriously to what do you make them
of how do a leader and members of the
shadow cabinet have reacted to this you
say that we need to take it seriously
couldn't have a look now at some of the
reasons that some of your shadow cabinet
and Jeremy Corbyn gave for losing
copeland fake news a leadership election
that ended five months ago
tony blair the political establishment i
mean if you look at that it looks a bit
as though Labour's trying to blame
everyone else apart from themselves a
bit quite like the kind of tactics you
might see in a schoolyard yeah I I'm I'm
not here to blame anybody else okay and
also I'm not here to lay the blame
simply on our leader and I think far too
much of British politics is personalised
it's personalized or around leaders it's
personalized around individuals in fact
I think and it's not just the Shadow
Cabinet either members of parliament the
Labour members of parliament are the
leaders of the Labour Party and we all
have a responsibility to be getting our
message across now we're on the backfoot
stoke and Copeland have put us on the
back foot that's absolutely clear out
there in the electorate we're on the
back foot but look in the House of
Commons we're actually on the front foot
in the House of Commons we're the ones
that are making the play and forcing the
government on the back foot about Social
Care we're the one that you are forcing
the government on so they wouldn't be
doing it if we had enforced my yes you
know on business rates on funding
formulas all of these things are things
that we in the Labour Party look at what
Debbie Abrams has been doing
over this past few days over the issue
of disability benefits the courts say
that the government should be giving 3.7
billion pounds to disabled people in
this country which the government is now
trying to stop
so actually what we're doing in
Parliament has been really successful
you see we're actually holding them to a
cup you say that it's not about Jeremy
Corbyn but it's hard to escape the view
that at least part of this is because of
your leader I didn't either
Sofia sorry I didn't say that Sofia I
said it's not only about only about we
all share that responsibility so
leadership is about all of the MPs not
just about one oh so you accept them
that he needs to take some blame of
course then he accepts that as well
a comrade Sunday mayor poll out today
seventy-seven percent of voters think he
should be replaced his personal approval
rating is minus 38 people have always
told us that the more the public will
see of Jeremy Corbyn the more they like
him but the opposite can I just say to
you the the thing that would please the
Conservative Party more than anything
else is if the Labour Party went to do
yet another leadership election it would
be insane we know that the public do not
like divided parties the Tories found
that out to their cost a few years ago
we are now finding out two eyes okay but
the divisions and the Labour Party
reflect and this is this is the
important thing here because this isn't
about a few politicians in Westminster
it's about what's happening in our
country and how we're responding to it
and what's happening in the country is
actually brexit has divided us in a way
that no other political issue has done
for 50 years brexit has actually meant
that two-thirds of those Labour MPs who
voted to remain are actually sitting in
seats who voted to leave they feel
themselves desperately vulnerable and
therefore they're deeply concerned about
the future of the party now they need to
focus on how they connect with their
electorate as all of us - but the other
part of this is that two-thirds of
labour voters in the public at large
actually wanted to remain so we in the
Labour Party are divided in a way that
no other
our tears so our constituencies are
going one way a membership or going the
other and what we've got to do as labor
members of parliament as the leaders of
the party is to get out there and start
talking to people start saying to people
okay what are the issues what are the
things that really are making you afraid
of how politics is going today you know
when your children cannot get a mortgage
because there are no houses being built
but you know when they're insecure jobs
people are being put on zero-hours
contracts and flexible jokes about them
no challenges for labour there are clear
challenges for labour but sometimes from
an outside perspective it can look as
though you're retreating onto
comfortable territory we can just show
you quickly now what was written on some
election material in Copland mothers
will die babies will die babies will be
brain-damaged I mean putting to one side
the fact that that's got the subtlety of
a hammer you literally said that babies
will die if the Conservatives get
elected and people still vote a
conservative look that's a quote from a
midwife a midwife who knows that if you
are in West Cambria and being forced to
travel 40 miles in labor in a difficult
labour to go to a hospital in Carlisle
that Midwife was saying quite rightly
that babies you know are then going to
be vulnerable and I understand but I
understand your point as well and your
point is we aren't really treating to
the core issue of the NHS and for it
can't be a single issue party we Barry
Gardner thank you very much for being
with us thank you